guys the views are amazing but where's
the delicacy
this is that spiny plant the cactus on
the edge of the cliff
yeah right off that Cliff Rose and
really dangerous places
this is crazy why aren't you coming
Arash
I'm afraid of heights man you're afraid
of heights go on dispatch
tres
they buy this
yes we can
and looking back don't lean forward
I'm Gordon Ramsay and I'm on an epic
adventure Taxi
traveling to the ends of the Earth
ditching the chef whites and getting
Hands-On
things I do for food
where do we start we want to start up
there
are you trying to kill me in search of
coloring inspiration
I've learned more in the last week than
I have the last 10 years this is
definitely Uncharted Territory for me it
doesn't get any better than that does it
foreign
this is Peru's sacred Valley
at towering Heights of up to three miles
above sea level it's a unique Andean
ecosystem whose staggering biodiversity
once fed the mighty income Empire
and now it's going to feed a British
chef with a motorbike
[Music]
unlock this Valley's secret I'm meeting
up with one of South America's Finest
chefs on the side of a mountain
obviously
how are you
Aurelia Martinez is famous for his
modern Twist on Traditional High
Altitude Cuisine he's cooking up a storm
in the food world and is basically a
younger better looking Peruvian version
of me damn him
good to see you man I'm so happy to be
here yeah seriously I am here to learn
discover where do we start and where
we're going to go well we're going to
start up there
over there we'll get the best view of
the circle Valley price yeah I mean you
you want to fill this extreme altitude
it's totally another world wow come out
of breath already
let's go vamos
of course the best view of the Sacred
Valley would have to be a 1300 foot
climb up a sheer rock face
for a challenge like this you need
balance courage and above all
comprehensive insurance
chefs should not be scaling 400 meter
cliffs
I mean normally chefs Bond over dinner I
can't believe we're bonding on a cliff
Edge on a mountain
how are we feeling now breath is very
short
we're now close to 10 000 feet above sea
level here there's 30 less oxygen in the
air
Purdue how come you're not out of breath
you're running up here like a guinea pig
chasing dinner yeah experts recommend
taking six days to acclimatize to the
altitude I've had almost six minutes
oh man
there's a loose Rock here by the way
[Music]
are you trying to kill me
if trousers have turned brown
I get the view
the view is incredible
amazing yes I'm out of breath but I get
it
yeah this is why I brought you here like
you have to experience this being in in
the altitude
should we eat
this is very traditional
oh Lord
so have you ever had a bad guy before no
no no no never so it's like a it's like
a jerky jerky yeah it's like beef jerky
of course yeah we dry this for 24 hours
and wow that's delicious
does the altitude make a massive
difference on taste taste is deep right
dense concentrate yes their conditions
are very extreme so these ingredients
has to be protected by themselves so
they are full of proteins that they are
concentrated by flavor but taste
one of the main things is that food is
protected by altitudes it's pure I
suppose it's very pure we don't have to
say we have organic things I mean that
word that doesn't have a meaning here
very good yeah how many puts Jack in a
completely different level so now you
have time to study the Cyber Valley
right and I want you to cook something
Peruvian for local Indian Farmers yeah
yeah come together together
a cook-off at the end of the week end of
the week
stay back
that was quite the climb and we've now
established two things peruvians look
better than Brits in plastic climbing
helmets
[Music]
and I've just got five days to uncover
the secrets of the Sacred Valley so
devise a feast that shows that handsome
devil Rogelio who's boss so lung
screaming I'm heading 5000 feet further
up for a lesson in the ancient art of
Andean cooking wow come on look at this
oh my Lord
peace
it's incredible
[Music]
now this is to start one of the highest
parts of the Sacred Valley and I'm here
to meet some Farmers that are still
farming from this land but using
techniques
dating back to the interest
because my Spanish is as good as my rock
climbing the family I'm meeting has
asked a friend to translate
Celine Hi how are you Dolly I'm good how
you doing yeah good to see you oh my
Lord come on seriously I know I know
amazing at the family here yeah they're
here Mario Maxima
nice to see you please
[Music]
oh hello this is
Sebastian and this is hello
congratulations having the most gorgeous
Back Garden anywhere in the world
Sebastian ah
the family has invited me to dinner a
classic Andean dish made from local
ingredients and it looks like I'm
playing sous chef
okay great thank you
is a soup with an amazing special recipe
these are the dry potatoes rice
it's amazing how hard they are they're
solid they're like pebbles
now we're going to make tuna flour oh
sorry Sebastian I don't want you on
getting you like that this is the
largest pestle of water I've seen in my
entire life so literally
you gotta do it stronger and faster
how do you stop the potatoes falling out
sorry
this reminds me of a
Fred Flintstone outside kitchen
wow how come nobody else is out of
breath
ah
back
that's hard really
the next ingredient in our soup is a
herb that thrives at 14 000 feet with
this recipe I can definitely cancel my
gym membership so he does this every day
he just fit as a butcher's dog wait
marry two sex
yeah it's amazing
how easy it is to get out of breath
now
let's go let's go
[Music]
I thank you
oh man Mario wants you to go get it
foreign
whatever
yeah
it is literally breathtaking
slippy
there's nothing to grab onto
use Flash in the Andes high altitude
herb gardens are a little different to
those back home
at least I've still got my dignity
Mario
honestly
I'm glad you're having a fun time up
there
boom
look at this so it looks a little bit
like time
very floor
very fragrant
it's lovely
how much we need yeah that's good he
says that's it wow that smells amazing
and
it's free
With A Fistful of herbs and a leg full
of bruises it's off to the family
kitchen to get cooking beautiful
boy oh boy
look at this place
and that there
that's obviously the stove
oh
look at them
in the Andes guinea pigs are known by a
different name
dinner
wow look at that
yeah
the action looks delicious I mean
seriously
the fact is the live ones are running
down there the ball wasn't hanging off
the wall
and guess who's next in line
over there at nine o'clock
[Music]
while the guinea pig Rose a sentence I
thought I'd never say prep continues for
the ancient Indian soup lower the tuna
we have the herb this smells amazing I
so in many ways the whole family is
self-sufficient from the land
that is incredible
I love sleeping around kitchens what's
all that up there the top of the uh the
big white stuff this is the lambaka
manure for the stove good stuff and that
because it burns good fuel yeah
I just love the fact that none of you
waste anything see it
potatoes in yeah
all of it yeah
what is that
you turn the gas up
gotcha my love ready
[Applause]
cheese I'd never thought about finishing
a lamb and potato soup with cheese
amazing
and look at that baby beautiful we
should open a restaurant together
Mama this deserves champagne napkins
let's go babies
mmm
before we eat Mario is going to make an
offering to the Mountain Gods
foreign
eating this now when we've just been sat
there with them about their heads
I'll go for the line the line the line
the Lloyd
pretty good
it's like a suckling pig excellent
soup
it was good it's like a traditional
British old-fashioned stew but this
thing's got more depth
because it's a high altitude
sort of cooking every ounce of flavor
you taste individually
and really delicious
thank you
that was extraordinary
because that is a proper Insight
something as basic as the hearts can
produce a dish like that that's
highlighting Health to cooking at its
best
already I'm starting to think you know
how I'll use that
what an amazing family and what an
amazing dish
I need
oh no come on
maybe it's the incredible Hospitality
shown by my new Indian family or the
fresh guinea pig coursing through my
veins but I'm even more determined to
win the battle with Rogelio
so I've enlisted the help of haresh a
Russian supplier with culinary contacts
all over the valley he's told me about a
local delicacy that tastes like shrimp
crust with calamari
you're telling me that this delicacy is
sought after and has only found at this
height yeah and there's the man that
knows how to find them
good to see him I am Keen to see this
delicacy
[Music]
La Comida Rica
the cactus see that's the delicacy there
on the edge of the cliff
is
Captain let's go
let's go let's go let's go
um
yeah in special
always
[Music]
seriously
oh man
[Music]
momentum you are crazy
okay let's see over 30 years of working
as a chef has all been leading to this
moment catching a Peruvian Cactus worm
with a lassoon
[Music]
all right good job
[Laughter]
you gotta get up here first oh man
excuse me that is not funny
be careful see this is super dangerous
foreign
[Laughter]
cancer
is
they're like giant caterpillars yeah how
did he first learn about these Nosotros
is
excellence and how would we first start
to dangle off the side of a cliff with
your dad looking for worms
six or seven amazing
all right
I'm just gonna get them a little bit dry
yeah just so it doesn't Crackle
okay
whoa
are you okay
[Laughter]
thank you this is where Italian
vegetarian
stop it yeah
foreign
[Music]
them
[Laughter]
it's like a it's like a crispy
like a crispy
cockroach
[Laughter]
[Music]
crispy to begin with fine however the
inside no no bueno but this is how they
survived so remotely protein growing
literally in a cactus so an amazing
secret and a big iron
I'm Blown Away by the ingenious ways and
the young people get their ingredients
it's the first time I've ever taken a
lasso to go food shopping
[Music]
but with just three days left one thing
is certain I won't beat Chef Aurelio
serving a plate of worms so it's time to
ditch the motorbike and get my head in
the clouds
now we're heading up over these
mountains to the Jungle because thousand
meters love sea level there's the most
amazing Farms have produced exotic
fruits I've never tasted high altitude
fruits and I'll die to see the
difference the level of concentrated
sweetness against acidity and I hear the
size of them are absolute gigantic
coming into land
anything
this is the Kia Bamba jungle
that to be home to the best fruit in the
world amazing
[Music]
and I'm heading to a family farm packed
with the biggest mango trees I've ever
seen
finally what is
I'm okay thank you good to see you yeah
oh my Lord
um so happy to be here
video has said that you had the best
exotic fruit yes we do indeed what's so
special about the fruit here
a lot more sugary yes indeed so more
in-depth flavor yes because of the
altitude amazing amazing okay how do we
get them okay you can go on my shoulders
[Laughter]
the mangoes are 100 feet up
only the youngest fittest locals pick
them
until now
am I getting a harness
okay guess
thank God for that
don't let me drop okay if I drop the
food world is
you ready David you good
let's go
okay oh my Lord
go to your
we're going to the Rope now or not
gotcha so he's going around the outside
yes and you need to follow him
okay David here I come
I've never made love to a tree
[Music]
you can do it yeah
try to push yourself up with your left
elbow
I'm stuck
okay now
I need you to get the mangoes from here
because there's no way those branches
either take my weight
please
let's go
I haven't climbed a tree for decades and
I'm I mean decades
you know I was worried I'd snap those
branches then we'd all come down so last
thing I want to do is go into this
incredible jungle and damage an amazing
tree that's been there for centuries
[Music]
look at that
wow that
it's delicious it's so juicy
the difference in the flavor was
extraordinary because it's highly
concentrated so it just bursts with
flavor
an amazing discovery
it's been a real eye-opener to see how
much the strong sun and low humidity
enhance the fruit sweetness
that amazing mango will definitely be on
my cook-off Feast menu and if Rogelio
asks trust me I've picked it myself okay
[Music]
now this country's famous for his
incredible fish and this Lake produces
them
come on look at this place honestly he
thought Scotland was beautiful this
beats it hands down
at 11 000 feet Lake hypo is one of the
highest in the world
and it's the breeding ground for
Peruvian Silverside a sacred Valley
staple
I'm down to meet an amazing fisherman
Domingo who is a dab hand at fishing and
like all good Scotsman trust me I grew
up with a rod and reel so hey Capitan
how are you good to see you we're good
see I'm so happy to be here now the fish
locally are
small big big fish excellent and we're
going to use a um Fly
what is that
that's it let's see no oh my Lord and
where have you parked the boat
this is the boat ready
what
what's the boat made of what
inner tubes and bottles and bits of
float
incredibly and the in fishing boats are
often made of trash okay
oh my lordy for the locals these
ingenious low-cost crafts are
lightweight and maneuverable
but for me
not so much
holy mackerel Domingo I think this
thing's gonna burst any minute
oh my Lord gracias
if we sink how deep is it in there
foreign
[Music]
fish jump
Domingo's teaching me his highly
technical style of line fishing so let's
take some bait
be good
show me I see
[Music]
box
oh
trust me
you think this looks easy it's way
harder than it looks I'm telling you
well I've been fishing for thousands of
hours we never give up
kill all fishes
[Music]
okay
got the fish
[Laughter]
so I
trust me
I'll take after all that hard work
honestly
okay I'll take the scales off
to prepare our pint-sized Peruvian
Silverside Domingo has a paste
what's in here
what is that chili
[Music]
look at that
tiny fish two grown men so we're gonna
eat this slowly on this lunch you can
use it as we're not gonna get fat
delicious we'll see
and your boating technique is incredible
excellent
[Music]
that was amazing fish was almost like a
cross between a catfish and a trout very
sweet very flaky it was really really
good they had this chili paste
marinating the fish in that paste with
that chili and those herbs you know it's
got me thinking big time
[Applause]
Peru's famous for his Pace but I have an
idea for a high altitude twist that
might just help me kick ferulio's ass
[Music]
and with 24 hours till the cook-off I
want to get my hands on a food and the
ends with the first people on Earth to
cultivate
[Music]
now this farmer produces the most
amazing potatoes in fact he's actually
known as The Mad potato scientist also
he's known for producing the most
amazing beer so I can't wait to meet
this guy in haresh he's gonna introduce
me to absolutely very he actually is
the Mad potato scientists
everything's going on about these
amazing potatoes what's so special about
them
foreign
wow
stop it blue have you been drinking
no
let's cook it see if it's blue
with these mad science skills Manuel
cross-pollinate high altitude potato
strains once used by the Incas
and for lunch his proud parents had
prepared some of the results
look like oh boy man
that is amazing
look at that oh my God it's like a
beetroot it does not look like a potato
you are a crazy scientist oh boy you can
just see that starch coming out there
so how did you cook them they're baked
in an oven roasted I'm dying to taste
these please
[Music]
the whole thing it's almost meaty man is
apparently these stunning pigments
protect the potatoes from the intense
ultraviolet light here at altitude what
a gift from the Mountain Gods
this one's in a surprise even more
that's incredible how the hell do you
peel something like that I mean
literally
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is unique to the Andean Highlands
[Music]
and the sweetness from those wild
strawberries are delicious
thank you Bravo thank you Bravo this is
very dangerous for me high altitude
alcohol and something that's incredibly
more
this is the kind of discovery that sends
me straight back to my kitchen because
I've just tasted the most amazing
potatoes I mean extraordinary the
different colors
a different flavor the diversity is
mind-blowing
and then the teacher I mean that will
wipe the smile off any any Frenchman's
uh Vineyard let me tell you sold their
pink champagne from now on in thank you
excellent thank you
it's the day of the cook-off so me and
my hangover are hitting urabamba the
sacred Valley's largest town on a last
minute mission to find Connery
inspiration and maybe some aspirin wow
oh my loss now that is what I call a
market
look at the colors
and you know damn well that everything's
been hand grown hand-picked and
literally hours ago plucked straight
from the sacred Valley
right
time to dive in
hold up
[Music]
this one what is this
is
good luck I won't be needing that but
just in case yes
potatoes extraordinary
salts
from the local salt mines the way that
glistens it's almost like little rough
cut diamonds beautiful I'm hoping these
diamonds are a chef's best friend
[Music]
oh my Lord
amazing
[Music]
six avocado please
a couple of bowls of garlic and I've
just spotted a big fan of the Red Hot
Chili Peppers
you want me to bite it at seven o'clock
in the morning
see that is hot you eat this for
breakfast
man
my map is on fire thank you thank you
thank you thank you oh my Lord
armed with a chili from my Peruvian
Spice Girl I'm ready to face my Connery
foe so I'm heading to Mill a sacred
Valley Restaurant eleven and a half
thousand feet up for my cook-off with a
prince of Peruvian cuisine virulio
Martinez ready to go hey oh man look at
this place you're good
first of all that
is a spot for a restaurant honestly
you're a lucky boy so uh what a week
I have been everywhere I understand the
sacred Valley like is the back of my
hand you're crazy man I'm hoping so you
did your homework I did do my homework
so I'm dying to get into the kitchen
because I want to show you what I've
understood and got up to speed with no
kitchen we're gonna cook Outdoors
you see the fire and
this is your stove you know this is our
technology seriously yeah
I'll stop it yeah bloody hell
[Music]
I'm gonna show you your kitchen now I've
never cooked on a stove like that yeah
you know we're calling it here uh yeah
this technique how far does this go back
this is very traditional this is very
Inca and it's stuck together with the
mud yep wow foreign
cooking with a mud oven is not what I
had planned I'm the outsider so I've got
to put my game face on and get dirty
this is my personal station you're a
bitter
this is my my stove I've invited the
farmers I met this week to the feast so
I need to show them their lessons
haven't gone to waste
ful
ass
back
I first tasted this meat five days ago
and no it's not a giant guinea pig look
at this thing yeah the pack is bigger
than him
right choose your Cuts I'm gonna go for
the saddle or the easy one that's nice
no because there's no fat on there I'll
pick that at the neck I'm gonna use some
some of that of the tongues the easy
part there you go what about the heart I
love heart
you know these guys uh the farmers uh I
was cooking before you they okay but
these Farmers they eat I mean they're
very used to eat hard yeah so it's gonna
be tough for you okay so settle half for
me you want to go for the most delicious
part in the neck let's go
I'm excited nervous at the same time
this cook is serious and I've got a draw
on everything I've learned all week
understood
search for doug4
fish for climb four and been out of
breath for the sacred Valley it's it's
like this Oasis a high altitude now it's
time to put it on the plate
there's no fat on this line so I just
want to make sure
they usually a pack of fat rendered down
almost like we do
additional Goose fare
the alpaca Hearts hit the stove
but it's me that's feeling the Heat
what are you doing there with that paste
I'm doing my marinade
lots of green herbs a little bit of
water the level of expectations are huge
you may be a greyhound up the mountain
side but trust me I do have an advantage
in the kitchen is she gonna taste
ferrillio might sense Victory with his
neck marinade but I'm about to unleash
my secret weapon
well I'm gonna start my pace using those
amazing mangoes
and some chili
I love it
how do you feel yeah
[Music]
from my lungs to the alpaca Hearts to
virulio's tongue it's all happening so
beautiful
this is like a little gastric
is done with the natural sugar
and they'll pack us like a mature
it's almost like a mature Lamb with a
little hint of sweetness
so I'm going to glaze that as they cook
virilio's now cooking his final alpaca
dish
why'd you put brains in omelettes what's
wrong with you
hey come here farmers
the pressure's on
cool members
my corner comes on fire
if they survive the stove I'll be
serving the corn with Manuel's
incredible multi-colored spuds how's
your heart apparently right now oh those
hearts yeah they're they're a lot more
relaxed than my heart right now okay
Julio
heart's done yeah
they're happy with to go pink right yeah
yeah just to make sure that they're not
calling inside yeah
beautiful
and now it's time to Plate up I mean let
me know when you're ready yeah I'll be
one minute
what do you think when there is when I
say about your potatoes I'm hoping next
time he cooks them my way
he's gonna get married
how are you give me just give me give me
30 seconds
finally my Feast is finished I've added
my mango paste to the loins plus Manuel
spuds and I'm hoping the hearts are
cooked to Perfection this looks
beautiful
really beautiful
but the competition is fierce
quinoa and tongue salad alpaca brain
omelette
and a next stew
okay good yeah let's go
I'm the pink man from Great Britain
smell
s beautiful braised Hearts now who's
gonna say grace foreign
[Music]
you've got the best ingredients look
from this Valley so it's sacred for a
reason
these Farmers the hardest customers
anywhere on the planet why
salt the Earth
[Music]
there's nothing to do now except wait
for the verdict
[Music]
this is not about winning it's about
pleasing and it's also about not losing
face with the locals in front of one of
Peru's culinary Legends
do you think they're enjoying it no idea
man they're speaking creature
serious
ly
there we go
fingers crossed we're good faces okay
is
okay so that one won the popular vote
the potatoes with the cheese sauce your
potatoes amazing but they don't actually
like everything the dish she first
pointed to the heart the heart she said
it's undercooked that's why they haven't
eaten so much of that nice
thank you guys okay how is the loin of
the alpaca
yeah he loved it they said it's the best
dish sorry just just say that again
please
the potatoes of the Lord
and they like that I think that's the
brain dish right okay it sounds like
it's sort of 50 50. okay
an amazing week in the sacred valid and
thank you for making me feel so welcome
Cheers Cheers
what an amazing week
and a dream come true why
because here in the sacred Valley I've
uncovered a truly mind-blowing culinary
culture using the secrets of the Incas
amazing Andean Ingenuity and stunning
altitude enriched ingredients the food
here kicks the ass of any fancy
restaurant breathtaking I don't know all
but definitely got a taste and now more
importantly
I'm on it's my next adventure take care
gracias gracias
[Applause]
[Music]